i was talking with dom a couple of
months ago and we were talking about how
you guys were supposed to have that
super group i mean you have talked about
it before with him
and nip yeah right which would have been
amazing um
is there is there any of those records
that exist anywhere that you guys cut
that never seen the light of day
like i don't think me dominip got in the
studio to start working on that like we
was having a conversation
and we was
finna go get a deal for that
before we even started working on it but
then me and nip
what i mean it was supposed to do
like we linked up to do
a group project probably like two three
times
in the last time no
the last time
the time before the last time was
when we did [ __ ] donald trump
me and him was working on a group
project called two of america's most
wanted
and that's where the [ __ ] donald trump
record came from so we got records from
that
from that time so the so you you and
nipsey have some unreleased stuff that
says
sitting on a hard drive somewhere yeah
we got unreleased stuff
but it ain't it ain't like to a point to
where i could like put it out or like it
ain't
like
we was just getting started on working
on a project and like we did like
like two three songs and [ __ ] donald
trump and
you feel me that was the best song
from that batch of songs and we end up
putting it out
so at that time we like when we put our
[ __ ] down trump we like [ __ ] we need the
project for we already like we made this
lit yeah we made the best record the
eyes on your head everybody yeah we made
the best like we made the best record
and make the biggest statement man that
was that spoke to that project like i
remember because it was around that time
you were on tour with g right and y'all
did the remix
and uh
that was like super thick in election
season yeah that [ __ ] was crazy that
[ __ ] was a wild time man you shot off uh
of the g-eazy because he you know i'm
saying he took a stance
you know what i'm saying with us on that
yeah and you had mclemore you just had
like the woke white dudes on the remix
um would you do a part two to that if he
runs again in 2024
no my bro nip ain't here
you see me so i gotta let that you know
i'm saying i gotta let that be that